Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Doki Doki Literature Club!
Okay! Alright! Everybody hold onto your horses 'cause I got the poem of your dreams right here.
Alright, who do I show it to first?
Hey Monika!
EEEEEY Monika baby!
Hang on I better save on this one.
It's a genius poem. Can't let the genius go to -- HEY Monika!
Hey come here!
I should start with Monika.
Yesterday she seemed eager to read my poem and I want her to know I'm putting in effort.
Puttin' in effort, Monika!
"Hi, Morp!"
Hi, Monika.
"Having a good time so far?"
Sure, okay.
Ah... yeah. "Good, glad to hear it!"
"By the way, since you're new and everything..
If you ever have any suggestions for the club, like new activities or things we can do better..
I'm always listening!"
And then I'll ignore you. And punch you in the face for daring to change my beautiful club.
"Don't be afraid to bring things up, okay?"
Alright, I'll keep that in mind.
Of course I'll be afraid to bring things up.
I'm much better off just going with the flow until I'm more settled in.
"AAAAAnyway.."
"Wanna share your poem with me?"
It's kind of embarrassing but I guess I have to.
"aHAHAhahaHahahAHA!"
"Don't worry, Morp. We're all a little embarrassed today, you know?"
You know, I don't trust you.
But that's okay.
"But it's the sort of barrier that we'll all learn to get past soon."
Yea, that's true.
I hand Monika my poem.
"...Mhm. Great job, Morp!"
"I was going 'OoOoh' in my head while reading it."
Not out loud though, I would never do that.
"It's really metaphorical."
"I'm not sure why but I didn't expect you to go for something so deep."
"I guess I underestimated you."
Hey! Sure! Was it the vivacious?
It was probably the vivacious.
It's easiest for me to keep everyone's expectations low.
That way it always counts when I put in some effort.
"HA! That's not very fair."
"Well, I guess it worked out anyway."
"You know that Yuri likes this kind of writing, right?"
"Writing that's full of imagery and symbolism."
"Unlike Sayori, who likes simple and direct words to describe happiness and sadness."
"Yuri likes when readers are left to derive their own meaning out of it."
"It's very challenging to write like that effectively."
"Both allowing people to get something out of it just by feel..
Or letting them deeply analyze all of the nuances."
"It can take years of practice-- which I'm assuming Yuri has at this point."
I never really asked though, I'm sure I'm nowhere NEAR her level yet.
"Ah, don't worry so much about that."
"You do your own thing."
"Just keep exploring and learn by trying new things."
I'm sure I'll end up trying different things a lot!
It could take a while before I'd feel comfortable doing this.
"That's okay!"
"I'd love to see you try new things."
"That's the best way to find the kind of style that suits you!"
"Everyone else might be a little bit biased towards their own kinds of styles..
But I'll always help you find what suits you the most."
"So don't force yourself to write the way everyone else wants you to write."
"It's not like you have to worry about impressing them or anything."
"Ahaha!" Okay, I don't like this.
"Anyway, you- you want to read my poem now?"
"Don't worry, I'm not very good."
You sound pretty confident for someone who claims to not be very good.
"Well, that's 'cuz I have to sound confident."
"That doesn't mean I always feel that way, you know."
I see.
Well, let's read it, then.
Ah.
"Hole in the Wall"
"It couldn't-"
What kind of hole are we talking about?
"It couldn't have been me.
See, the direction the spackle protrudes.
A noisy neighbor?
An angry boyfriend?
I'll never know. I wasn't home.
I peer inside for a clue.
No! I can't see. I reel, blind, like a film left out in the sun.
But it's too late. My retinas.
Already scorched with a permanent copy of the meaningless image.
It's just a little hole. It wasn't too bright.
It was too deep.
Stretching forever into everything.
A hole of infinite choices
I realize now that I wasn't looking in
I was looking out.
And he, on the other side, was looking in."
Beautiful.
"So what do you think?"
Oh! [kissing noise]
I've never been so excited about a hole in my life!
Oh it's a beautiful thing!
Hmm. It's very freeform, if that's what you'd call it.
Sorry, I'm not really the right person to ask for feedback.
"Hahaha, it's okay."
"Yeah, that kind of style has gotten pretty popular nowadays."
"That is, a lot of poems have been putting emphasis on the timing between words and lines."
"When performed out loud, it can be really powerful."
What was the inspiration behind this one?
"Ah. Well, I'm not sure if I know how to put it."
"I guess you could say that I had some kind of epiphany recently."
"It's been influencing my poems a bit."
An epiphany?
"Yeah, something like that."
"I'm kinda nervous to talk about deep stuff like that because it's kind of coming on strongly."
"Maybe after everyone is better friends with each other."
"Anyway. Here's Monika's writing tip of the day!"
"Sometimes when you're writing a poem or story, your brain gets too fixated on a specific point."
"If you try so hard to make it perfect, then you'll never make any progress."
"Just force yourself to get something down on paper, and tidy it up later."
"Another way to think about it is this."
"If you keep your pen in the same spot for too long, you'll just get a big dark puddle of ink."
"So just move your hand and go with the flow."
"That's my advice for the day."
"Thanks for listening~"
Alright. Cool. Alright. Who should I show my poem to next?
I don't know... I don't...
How about no one?
Oh NatSUUKII!
Sayooori?
Natsuki. I haven't talked to you yet.
Eeeey, waddup?
"Well, it's about what I expected from someone like you."
What?! Excuse you!
That's a little blunt.
"Well, excuse me."
"It's not like I said that was bad."
"It just didn't evoke any emotions."
So basically it's not cute enough for your tastes?
"Do you want to get smacked?"
I'll pass.
"*sigh*"
"Well anyway, I guess I need to show you mine."
"Not that you'll like it."
"Eagles Can Fly"
"Monkeys can climb
Crickets can leap
Horses can race
Owls can seek
Cheetahs can run
Eagles can fly
People can try
But that's a-bout it."
Aw, that's beautiful!
That's beautiful!
I like it.
I really like it! I actually like it.
"I told you that you weren't going to like it."
I like it!
"What?"
"Just be honest!"
I am.
Why are you so convinced that I wouldn't like it?
"WELL-"
UUUHHH-
"Because!"
"Everyone in high school thinks that writing has to be all sophisticated and stuff."
"So people don't even take my writing seriously."
But isn't the point of poems for people to express themselves?"
Your writing style wouldn't make your message any less valid.
"Yeah! Exactly!"
"I like it when it's easy to read but it hits you hard."
"Like in this poem."
"Seeing everyone around you do great things can be really disheartening..
So I decided to write about it."
Yeah, I understand.
"But the other nice thing about simple writing is that it puts more weight on the wordplay."
"Like I set up for a rhyme at the end, but then made it fall flat on purpose."
"It helps bring out the feeling in the last line."
So you did.
I guess more went into it than I realized.
"That's what it means to be a pro!"
"I'm glad you learned something."
"Didn't expect that from the youngest one here, did you?"
Yeah, I guess not.
I decide to humor her with the last comment.
I don't really care how old everyone is, but if Natsuki is feeling proud then I won't take that away from her.
Aw.
How about Sayori? Sayori!
Hey Sayooori!
SaYaOwori!
"This is a good poem, Morp!"
"Are you sure it's your first time?"
Of course!
It's not that good.
Am I the kind of guy who would be writing poems in his spare time?
"Hehe, I guess you're right."
"You're pretty terrible."
"But that's why it impressed me!"
"Well, to be honest..
I was afraid that you wouldn't do it seriously."
"Or that you wouldn't write one at all."
"I'm really happy just that you wrote one."
"It reminds me of how you really are part of the club now."
Not to mention the fact that I'm standing in front of you in the club room?
Eh, well of course.
I'm not really into it yet, but that doesn't mean I'll break my promise.
"See?"
"It's like I said before, Morp..
Deep down, you're not selfish at all, you know?"
That's a backhanded compliment...
"Trying new things like this for other people..
That's something that only really good people do."
Thanks... I guess.
I'm not sure if Sayori sees the full picture of my motive here.
Then again, I can't deny that she's part of the reason I joined.
Knowing how much this means to her and all.
Yeah...
"and I'm gonna make sure you have lots of fun here, okay?"
Oh! Yeah alright.
Hang on, wait. I gotta save again. I don't know why, I just gotta save.
[laughs]
[laughs again]
I-- I-- sure. Okay.
I can't really see you as being cranky anyway.
You got it Sayori.
Huh. Interesting.
Alright well it's just Yuri left.
This hasn't taken a dark turn yet, but I got a funny feeling about it.
Ugh. Her mouth just grows exponentially and she has to keep that shit contained.
You've got great thumbs after all.
Alright so you're a ghost, is that what you're saying?
Your're a ghost. I get it, I see it ghost girl. Okay. I know. I get it.
Ah Morp very stupid! You need to understand this about Morp.
Morp very a dummy.
Eh?
blooh! [weird mouth noises]
Are you a ghost?
Your thumb felt very solid.
Your thumbs...
You got real teaching thumbs.
Okay! Alright.
Morp liked it! Morp liked it a lot!
Which yours was not.
[orgasm/mouth sound]
[weird sound]
[continues making odd noises that may be confused with certain sexual sounds]
[throat sound resembling "huh?!"]
UUGH! EEIY!
[sound resembling a deep screaming sheep]
[laughs]
Uh-- wha--? Natsuki!
My boobs have been the same size!
DDUUUR!
Hang on, I just gotta save. There's conflict here.
UUGH! UUUH? UUuUuUGH?!
Oh! Oh boy! Okay, conflict! Hang on.
Alright, I gotta think about his one.
Uh.
Put on my thinking pants!
Oh wait I'm not wearing pants...
MREH.
MMH.
Mm.
M.
NNAlright okay alright. Well.
Okay well Yuri's full of herself.
Yuri's full of herself. She's being a little uppity.
Being a little up... itty...
Natsuki was defensive off the bat...
But Yuri was dismissive off the bat. That's the two juxtapositions here.
Like, neither of them were right. I mean they're right in their own ways but obviously I can't take a side on it.
Maybe Sayori can help me...
Sayori!
Help! Please!
Heeelp!
Help! I really don't care what their opinions of me are!
UUURF. UGH.
Be-- Because Morp's so hot!
[laughs]
Big and beautiful!
Oh! Monika!
Why do I have a funny feeling this is going to take a horrifying turn?
Ah!
It's all your fault! It's your fault Morp!
It's your fault.
I might be in love with them!
In DA club!
[laughs suggestively/creepily]
Whap whap.
Righty-ho!
Something's not right here...
Something's not right...
HA! POOF!
Poof! Poof! Gotta go with poof!
POOF!
Uh... analysis.
Uh.. PLEAsure...
Um
In-- No-- Ah--
Lazy.
Uh
Sssspecial!
Vitality.
Um
Uh. Eeeessence.
Uh
BUNNY!
Um
Uh
Unrestrained.
Um
PURE!
Uh
Uwuwah... Tenacious... INCONGRUENT.
PApa.
Um, ah,
Adventure!
Uuuhahhh...
Socks.
I got special Markiplier socks.
They're pretty cool, they got chica on them.
Cheato Burrito .
Ignore the Chica hair on there.
That's gross.
Whistle~
Uh skipping?
Um
[deep voice] Climax.
BREF
Uh, disown.
Uuuuh
SUNNY!
Uuuum um
Boop! boop! Boop!
Boop! Boop. Boop.
Got it.
Okay.
Alright. I don't know where this is going.
Hehe, you're brain real simple Sayori.
What the hell?
A cookie!
I'm gonna save real quick...
Just something doesn't seem right...
Something doesn't seem right about this.
I just dabble in a few Beethoven's and some... [trails off into mumbles] ... Motzart's...
[breathes in] Anyway...
[burps] OoOOOOH EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY
Aw....
I've felt that feel many times.
Okay.
I tried it out with Yuri... With our thumbs almost touching.
You'll make me feel WEEEEIRD.
Ew.
Morp just meant that Morp hasn't seen you at your full power!
Well it is called 'Parfait Girls' so one would surmise that baking was a predominant feature in the thing. Yeah.
Oh! How adorable!
That's cutesy.
That's a cutesy wootesy.
It's not, I swear!
"I guess it's fun sharing something with--" someone you like.
Oh, oh, "Something you like with someone else."
Sorry, slip of the tongue.
A little 'froity and floop'.
I think that's what they call it...
MER. I don't have any friends.
Oh you really don't have friends, that's sad. Geez.
Like you! You loser!
Me am loser! You am loser, we am losers!
Right? You get it.
Someone who is an even bigger loser than I am, if you know what I mean.
Your life long dream. Morp coming and reading your manga.
Your dream come true you're welcome.
But Morp pretty sure it does!
Okay.
OKAY EVERYONE! SHUT YOUR TRAPS!
DING DONG BING BONG
Time to read your poems! Here Monika doth decree that it's time!
To do the reading of the poems thusly that is now!
You all ready? Get to your-- your ready positions I guess.
Right hang on.
Excuse my butt in your face, I just had to strike a pose...
I'm-- ah-- a grown adult.
I don't wanna know.
Uh, I do like that face!
Oookay that's too normal. I don't know why.
But somethin'-- Something's off. Something's off, I can tell!
I have an intuition about these things.
But I'm all out of time for this episode so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think in the comments below!
Write another poem down there if you would.
And uh, I will read them. I haven't had a chance to yet, because I've been recording a lot, but I will read those poems.
So thank you everybod again, and as always:
I will see you in the next video!
Buh bye!